let's take a a spin through the campaign
Trail and the last 24 hours a number of
former democratic presidents out on the
campaign Trail hoping to stem losses
hoping to create wins hoping to turn
maybe at least a couple of Elections one
of those individuals is former president
Barack Obama former president Barack
Obama really stung
Carey Lake and by extension Donald Trump
by pointing out we've tried electing
people who are just known for being on
TV and it didn't go particularly well
reports are many on the right
particularly upset by what Barack Obama
said yesterday during an event in
Arizona in support of Democrats running
in that state here in Arizona
there's no question that that Katie
hobbs's opponent she's good in front of
the camera because she's been doing it
for a long time right
so some people don't know this but uh
apparently Carrie Lake actually
interviewed me back in 2016 when I was
President true she was a she was a local
news anchor she was doing her job at the
time
I don't remember thinking that she was
the kind of person who would push
debunked covet remedies
or promise to issue a declaration of
invasion
at our border that's a very important
action or a claim without any evidence
that the 2020 election was stolen I
guess that stuff came later because
he found it convenient because he
thought well here's an opportunity to
get attention yep
listen it if we hadn't just elected
somebody whose main qualification was
being on TV
you could see maybe giving it a shot
what's the Worst That Could Happen well
now we know yeah it doesn't just work
out just because somebody's been on TV
uh President Obama is uh is is quite
good at this and indeed he is needed in
Arizona and the reason that he is needed
in Arizona is just look at the polling
Kerry lake is an individual who has no
business whatsoever
in public service she talked about
Arizona
seceding from the United States she
spreads the big lie she said she was
taking prophylactic Ivermectin on and on
and on and she is I don't even want to
say potentially I think at this point we
have to say if you believe the polling
she is the most likely Heir Apparent to
become the governor of Arizona currently
Kerry lake is leading Democrat Katie
Hobbs by an average of 2.8
now
what's going on with the polling do we
believe these numbers I don't know we
will have a report either tomorrow or
Monday about the allegations of bad
polling unreliable polling and push
polling related to the election
but why chance it why Chance it 2.8
maybe she's winning by 2.8 maybe it's a
tie or not your vote really matters this
time around and for everybody who says
well what do you mean my vote it's never
it never comes down to one vote here's
the the way you have to think about that
how often does the election come down to
one vote very rarely
but a lot of people say that to
themselves a lot of people say
why do I need to vote it never comes
down to one vote
if all the people who thought that
stayed home it would actually flip
elections and that's why it's important
when you say to yourself it never comes
down to one vote why do I need to vote
understand that there are thousands or
tens of thousands or hundreds of
thousands of other people saying the
same thing to themselves if you all stay
home one candidate wins if everybody who
has that thought votes the other
candidate wins so do not allow yourself
to fall into that thinking one other
funny Barack Obama clip from the Arizona
rally talking about Blake Masters that
really bizarre dude who's running
against Mark Kelly and also who might
win just very funny commentary about him
if you were trying to create
in a lab yes
a wacky Republican politician
it looked a lot like this guy
Mr Masters true
campaign backed by a tech billionaire
who's questioned the value of democracy
right check
got it wants to give caskets to Big
corporations that are jacking up prices
on consumers of course check
thinks it's a good idea to privatize
Social Security and quote cut the knot
on the benefits
that more than a million seniors here in
Arizona depend on
check check check
[Applause]
I I got a little fired up about this the
other day in Wisconsin but it's true
here in Arizona too
Polson Arizona has Social Security not
because somebody's giving it to him as a
payoff as a as a gift they earned it for
it that's exactly right and the social
security issue is increasingly becoming
an issue very good appearance by former
president Barack Obama he was not the
only former president out on the
campaign trail yesterday before you go
if you enjoyed this video and want to
see more please make sure to subscribe
to my YouTube channel you can click the
Subscribe button below or above or
wherever it is on your screen and if you
want to support my work even more
strongly the best way is to get a
membership at joinpakman.com And
subscribe to the podcast for the David
packman show there you can check out
interviews longer clips and much more
it's on all the big podcasting platforms
just search for the David packman show
and all the links are also Down Below in
the video description